hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the chapter situation and character
in Simone de Beauvoir work the second
sex one of the themes that she's really
going to highlight and it's one that
she's been talking about throughout the
work is the reduction of woman as a free
being as something that's capable of
transcendence to the realm of imminence
and thereby being put on the same level
as things even if one is talked about as
a person as a subject there's still an
objectification going on a reduction to
a thinly status so she she talks about
this as women being forced into a
condition of imminence and when we say
forced we don't mean that there's some
sort of you know corralling and you know
a big roster and and everyone has to
check off their thing okay you're not
transcendent you're imminent or anything
like that there's nothing like that
happening rather there's condition after
condition after condition at each life
stage in each situation showing women
that they're not going to be treated and
regarded and recognized the same as
sometimes even quite inferior men
inferior in many other respects women
are being given this status of eminence
and we could think you know just for
example of the stuff that still goes on
today in how the female body is treated
as an object and the male body is
treated as a locus of agency in so many
types of media whether it be in terms of
you know just sheer looking or who gets
to have lines in movies or as characters
we can go on and on and on with examples
like this and hopefully that won't be
the the issue you know decades from now
but it certainly is today that was very
much so in Simone de Beauvoir time so
women are are forced into imminence and
one of the reasons why she says that
women and you could say fulfilling this
expectation is because they have closed
horizons they are in many ways as she
says enclosed within the limits of one's
ego one one's own conception of of self
and all the accoutrements that go along
with that or the household and you know
today we could say well what about the
workplace that can still happen in in
the workplace too particularly when some
areas are regarded as being especially
women's work and we'll talk about that
in a bit but being enclosed within those
limits and then not being afforded a
full place in a larger male-dominated
world and you could say well wait a
second can't anyone go anywhere that
they want to you know how is a woman
confined to the household if she's able
to get on the train and go into the city
and go to work and then come back home
and go out get in the car and drive out
to a club or to a grocery store or a
movie theater or to some sort of
gathering or whatever you want right and
there are some truth to that but there
are
without necessarily being you know
completely male-dominated places that's
often gone by the wayside there aren't
so many old boys clubs but there's all
of these different ways in which women
are in fact unequal I'll just give you
one example I've never had a male
student in any of my many many classes
that I've taught tell me a story a
truthful story about an attempted
abduction on campus at night while he
was walking you know people trying to
pull him into a van I have had a female
student telling me that story and I
suspect that that's not the only one who
has run into situations like that and
I'm not using that to try to you know
characterize everything or blow it up
you know from an anecdote into a rule or
something like that but just to
illustrate as an example what we're
talking about here not being afforded a
full place in this larger male-dominated
world that still remains in many
respects so even if not necessarily
every male is able to participate within
that so what is the net effect of this
being forced into imminence means being
treated as a thing from an existential
point of view it means being treated as
something that has its being in itself
not being for itself even if it does in
fact have being for itself because every
human being does that human being is not
treated as such and so there's no
transcendence that is being recognized
sustained supported and there's a push
back into more and more imminence now I
do want to point out one thing that de
Beauvoir doesn't let women off the hook
for this she doesn't say that it's just
a matter of women being forced into this
one down position she says that you know
this is talking about sexual relations
but we could easily broaden this to all
sorts of others man demands play-acting
he
it's her to be the other but all
existence remains subjects try as they
will to deny themselves man wants woman
to be object she makes herself object at
the very moment when she does that she
is exercising a free activity therein is
her original treason the most docile the
most passive is still a conscious being
and sometimes the fact that in giving
herself to him she looks at him and
judges him is enough to make him feel
duped she is supposed to be only
something offered no more than prey he
also demands that this thing give
herself over to him of her own free will
and so there there's there's a dynamic
going on there that can't possibly be
satisfied and it's it's essentially what
the existentialist call bad faith now de
pouvoir doesn't say that you know women
are entirely responsible for that as a
matter of fact she thinks that the
male-dominated world has a greater
responsibility let's look at one of the
examples that she highlights in here
which i think is really quite apt and we
could extend it to many other things as
well and you probably have to exercise a
little bit of imagination to think about
what a kitchen was like in the day that
she's talking about so no microwave no
you know everything being meal planned
in the refrigerator everything has to be
done essentially from scratch no you
know highly processed foods or if there
are you know those are luxury items
there aren't a lot of mixes for things
at the time that she's talking about so
here's what she says and she makes a
really interesting reference here to
Martin Heidegger she says that woman
typically lacks the technical training
that would permit her to dominate matter
it's not matter she comes to grips with
but life and life cannot be mastered
through the use of tools the world does
not seem - woman woman an assemblage of
implements intermediate between her will
and her goals as Heidegger defines that
it's on the contrary something
obstinately resistant unconquerable it
is dominated by fatality and shot
through with mysterious caprices so she
goes on and she talks about the kitchen
each day the kitchen teaches her
patience and passivity and if you think
about the sheer act of cooking or doing
laundry or caretaking or all these other
things that we often call women's work
foolishly so but that that's a whole
different topic they do in fact involve
a certain passivity and patience
particularly if they're not highly
regarded if they don't provide a source
of transcendence
so she says here is alchemy one must
obey the fire the water wait for the
sugar to melt for the dough to rise also
for the wash to dry for the fruits to
ripen on the shelf household activities
come close to being technical operations
but they don't provide transcendence why
not because she says they're too
rudimentary too monotonous to prove to a
woman the laws of mechanical causation
and things are capricious they don't
always turn out the way they should
there are materials that will stand
washing others that won't spots that can
be removed others that persist objects
that break all by themselves dusts that
spring up by like plants and so not just
the kitchen but the entire realm of
household activities mundane activities
is sort of a trap of imminence she talks
about it involving routine monotony a
certain sort of temporality
she says it's easy to see why woman
clings to routine time for her has no
element of novelty it's not a creative
flow because she's doomed to repetition
she sees in the future only a
duplication of the past if one knows the
word in the formula duration a lies
itself with the powers of fecundity but
this is itself subject to the rhythm of
the months the seasons the cycle of each
pregnancy
in this play of cyclical phenomena the
sole effect of time is a slow
deterioration it wears out furniture and
closed as it ruins the face so this is a
way of looking at the world and at
things and at people in which no
transcendence is really possible and it
ends up being a sort of connection to
the world of things and eventually one
become something like a thing she also
talks about some of the criticisms of
women in terms of imminence particularly
in in relation to sensuality and she
says many of the faults for which women
are reproached simply Express the fact
that their horizon is closed it is said
that the woman is sensual she wallows in
imminence but she's been first shut up
in it and you could ask well what is
what does that mean then why why engage
why focused primarily on gratifying the
senses in different ways you might think
of women for example who stay at home
and redecorate and redecorate and
remodel their house over and over and
over again and then throw parties where
their friends come and chitchat about
that and look through magazines about
what else could be done there that would
be you know prime example why don't why
do people do that well there are three
things that the do boudoir actually
talks about here one is killing time she
brings up for example the harem slave
feels no morbid passion for Rose
preserves and perfumes baths she has to
kill time when a woman suffocates in a
doll Dyna sium brothel or middle-class
home she's bound to take refuge in
comfort and well-being right so that
that's another thing as well it feels
good it feels nice and these things
afford constellations or compensations
for the broader lie
and involvement and relationships that
she's not having you know do bar has
some some great examples here she says
if she really seeks sexual pleasure it's
very often because she's deprived of it
sexually unsatisfied doomed to male
crudeness condemned to masculine
ugliness she finds consolation in what
creamy sauces heavy wines Velvets the
caress of water of sunshine of a woman
friend of a young lover so you know you
think about all the consumer products
that we pitch to women so often this
body spray this you know shower curtain
to brighten up the house those are the
compensations for a life that in some
way is empty and then there's the people
often say well why are you looking for
this physical pleasure why are you for
example having an affair I wanted to
feel alive how often is that said well
she discusses that as well and you know
the call of the flesh she says there's
no louder in her that in the mail but
she catches this it's leashed murmurs
and amplifies them sexual pleasure like
rending pain represents the stunning
triumph of the immediate though the
violence of the instant the future and
the universe are denied what lies
outside the kernel flame is nothing for
the brief moment of this apotheosis
woman is no longer mutilated and
frustrated so those you know provide us
with excellent reasons why one might do
that she also does talk about this this
occupation with things why is it that
women seem to be so focused on having
stuff on accumulating materials and she
has this great discussion of means and
ends here in the work yeah here we go
she says if woman is earthy commonplace
basely utilitarian it is because she's
compelled to devote her existence to
cooking and washing diapers it's her
duty to assure
the monotonous repetition of life in all
of its mindless factual 'ti it's natural
for women to repeat to begin again
without ever inventing for time to seem
to go round and round without ever
leading anywhere she is occupied without
ever doing anything and thus she
identifies herself with what she has not
what she could be what she has this
dependence as de Beauvoir says on things
a consequence of the dependence in which
men keep her explains who forge out
frugality her avarice her life is not
directed this is the key point towards
ends
she has absorbed in producing or caring
for things that are never more than
means such as food clothing and shelter
these things are intermediaries between
animal life and free existence the sole
value that a pertains to the essential
means is utility and she goes on to say
that no existent can be satisfied with
an in essential role why for that
immediately makes means into ends as may
be observed in politicians and the value
of the means comes to seem and absolute
value so she says the utility rains and
the housekeeper's heaven above truth
beauty liberty and it is in this
perspective she envisioned envisages the
entire universe and what is this this is
another way of falling into imminence
into a realm of things and coming after
a while to treat oneself as just one
more thing among them not as a subject
so this is a very important diagnosis
that de pouvoir is engaging in she's not
saying that every single woman you know
she's not an essentialist
she's not saying this is the
characteristic of all she's saying that
this is the sort of situation that so
many women are forced into and we can
see that still going on today as well as
in her own time when she was writing
this book
you